I can't wait to fall in love Yeah and I
don't want to get married I want you to
have already had kids Wendy Williams
returning to the spotlight following her
release from a wellness facility we've
got a lot to talk about yep the 58 year
old TV personality got real about her
goals in the romance Department during
an interview at wbls's Circle of sisters
event in New York I can't wait to fall
in love Yeah and I don't want to get
married I wanted to have already had
kids I want him to be someplace between
some place around my age you know maybe
10 years younger than me and maybe 15
years older than me okay you know what I
mean and then we'll be able to do things
together so Wendy's not looking to get
married but she's hoping her new man's
open to traveling
who want to all of a sudden fly from New
York City if we want to fly to France to
be there for two days to have food or
whatever right I wanted to be able to
you know I can do qualified with a man
that come on baby let's do it do we fly
private okay but having love on the
brain isn't new for Wendy back in June A
source told E.T quote Wendy wants to
fall in love and knows that's exactly
what she deserves I don't have time for
a lot of foolishness her appearance
comes just one month after her exit from
a Wellness Center the former talk show
host took some time away from The Wendy
Williams Show to focus on her health I
feel like everybody deserves
um privacy I think that there's nobody
involved with Wendy Williams Show that
was happy about the way it ended many
people described a scenario where she
was sort of rambling she sort of became
incoherent it was very clear to
everybody watching this she wasn't fine
and that she wasn't going to sort of be
back at the show anytime soon the
concerns about out for health our best
this was a show that had been on the air
for 13 years there was a love for Wendy
herself as Wendy had a legendary career
in radio and this show was specifically
crafted for her no one can do this
format but Wendy Sherry Shepard guest
hosted the daytime talker through its
final days and eventually got a show of
her own and now your host Sherry Shepard
sometimes you just want to turn on the
TV and feel better than when you came so
I want to lift your spirits I have a
need to do it through laughter I want
you to smile that like this big gorgeous
smile that you have I want people to
smile I want people to feel seen I want
women my age to know that you still it's
not too late you can do anything in the
past Wendy's vowed she'll return to her
canceled talk show but for now Wendy's
publicist tells ET that she's taking
things one step at a time she attended
the radio stations event and quote
shared a momentous and sentimental
moment with the audience after taking
time off and focusing on herself she is
gracefully getting back to what she
loves
[Music]
foreign